This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mar- This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mar- I'm Roman Mars. The leaf blower is one of the most hated objects in the modern world. If you've lived pretty much anywhere in America in the last 40 years, you probably know their motorized wine. They're loud, they pollute, and how important is a leafless lawn anyway? In a lot of towns and cities, the gas-powered leaf blower has been banned. In others, there are strict guidelines on where and when they can be used, but in Los
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。吹叶机是现代世界中最令人讨厌的物品之一。如果你在过去40年里几乎住在美国的任何地方，你可能都知道它们那马达般的嗡嗡声。它们很吵，会造成污染，而且没有落叶的草坪到底有多重要呢？在许多城镇和城市，燃气吹叶机已被禁止使用。在其他地方，对于它们的使用地点和时间也有严格的规定，但在洛
Angeles, California, the leaf blower has never gone quiet. That's reporter Phil Corbett from a podcast called The Wind. In 2024, the state of California banned the sale of gas-powered leaf blowers. But this most recent development is just the latest shot in the Los Angeles leafblower wars. This is a fight that goes back decades. A fight that's kicked up questions about labor rights, environmental concerns, and ideas of beauty.
杉矶，加利福尼亚州，吹叶机从未安静下来。这是来自名为《风》的播客的记者菲尔·科比特。2024年，加利福尼亚州禁止销售燃气吹叶机。但这一最新进展只是洛杉矶吹叶机战争中的最新一击。这是一场持续了几十年的斗争。一场引发了关于劳工权利、环境问题和美学观念质疑的斗争。
In 1970s Los Angeles, it was common for people to hose down their driveways. Homeowners, renters, and gardeners would wash dirt and leaves and whatever else out onto the street. But a serious drought in 1976 and 77 spurred many Californians to start saving water and stop hosing everything down all the time. And as it just so happened, to meet this moment, a new piece of machinery was introduced to America. There's a lot of things we like to do outdoors, like golf, gardening, and backpacking with Echo.
在20世纪70年代的洛杉矶，人们用水管冲洗车道是很常见的。房主、租户和园丁会把泥土、树叶和其他杂物冲到街上。但1976年和1977年的严重干旱促使许多加州人开始节约用水，不再总是冲洗一切。正如巧合的是，为了适应这一时刻，一种新的机械设备被引入美国。我们喜欢在户外做很多事情，比如打高尔夫、园艺和带着Echo背包旅行。
The Japanese company Echo debuted what they called the cleanup machine. In fall, it rounds up a yard full of leaves in no time. company Echo debuted what they called the cleanup machine. In fall, it rounds up a yard full of leaves in no time. We use it year-round for garden grooming, sidewalk, patio, and driveway sweeping. Works great for snow blowing too. Originally invented as a crop dusting device in 1947, Echo soon realized that this machine had some serious leaf-moving properties. Fallen leaves had long been one of the main enemies of the perfect American lawn. At first, this clean-up machine, aka leaf blower, seemed to solve the problem perfectly. A drought-friendly way to move leaves and debris off your yard. That commercial shows a person with
日本Echo公司推出了他们所谓的“清理机”。在秋天，它能很快地把院子里的落叶聚拢起来。公司推出了他们所谓的“清理机”。在秋天，它能很快地把院子里的落叶聚拢起来。我们全年都用它来修剪花园、清扫人行道、露台和车道。它也非常适合吹雪。最初作为1947年的农作物喷粉装置发明，Echo很快意识到这台机器具有非常强大的落叶移动性能。落叶长期以来一直是完美美国草坪的主要敌人。起初，这种清理机，也就是吹叶机，似乎完美地解决了这个问题。这是一种对干旱友好的方式，可以将树叶和碎片从你的院子里移走。那则广告展示了一个人背着
a backpack engine set up, a big hose coming out, blowing leaves across a green lawn. What you can't really tell in that commercial is that these things were loud. These things were loud. Before the leaf blower, people were using gas-powered lawn mowers too. But adding another engine to a full lawn cleanup meant double the noise. By 1989, some estimates say that about 1 million leaf blowers had sold in America. But while they were ubiquitous, they were also almost universally hated. This noisy little machine could be used more often than a lawnmower, even daily.
背包式发动机，伸出一根大软管，把树叶吹过绿色的草坪。你在那则广告中真正看不出来的是，这些东西非常吵。这些东西非常吵。在吹叶机出现之前，人们也使用燃气割草机。但在完整的草坪清理中增加另一台发动机意味着噪音加倍。到1989年，据估计美国已经售出了大约100万台吹叶机。但虽然它们无处不在，却也几乎普遍受到憎恨。这种吵闹的小机器比割草机使用得更频繁，甚至每天都在用。
And some people wouldn't even use it to make leaf piles to bag up and remove, they just blow leaves into the street, or in the case of dust, up in the air. Through the 1980s facing pressure from homeowners and constituents in quiet neighborhoods, many city councils had introduced or passed outright bans on the leaf blower. From the start, Californian cities stood at the forefront of the war against the leaf blower, and the most high-profile ban in Southern California was in, you guessed it, Beverly Hills. In Southern California, there was a celebrity cast of characters speaking out against the
有些人甚至不用它来把树叶堆起来装袋清理，他们只是把树叶吹到街上，或者如果是灰尘的话，就吹到空中。在整个20世纪80年代，面对来自安静社区的房主和选民的压力，许多市议会已经引入或通过了对吹叶机的彻底禁令。从一开始，加州的城市就站在了反对吹叶机战争的最前线，而南加州最引人注目的禁令就在你猜对了，比佛利山庄。在南加州，有一群名人公开反对
blower. Not exactly household names today, but people who were well known at the time. One of the main proponents of the leaf blower ban was Peter Graves, the main actor in the original Mission Impossible TV show. This is from a PSA that Graves recorded. The video shows a man blowing leaves outside of an open window. Just inside, a baby is taking a nap. The evidence is mounting. Leaf blowers are dangerous.
吹叶机。虽然今天算不上家喻户晓的名字，但在当时却是广为人知的人物。吹叶机禁令的主要支持者之一是彼得·格雷夫斯，原版《碟中谍》电视剧的主演。这段音频来自格雷夫斯录制的一则公益广告。视频显示一名男子在开着的窗户外面吹树叶。窗内，一个婴儿正在睡觉。证据越来越多。吹叶机很危险。
But for all of their loudness and fumes, the leaf blower was also very fast at removing leaves from a yard. And for the people who were not just maintaining their own lawn, but many lawns, the speed was a big deal. Like a regular small house, maybe half an hour, 45 minutes. But a big house, you're going to spend like an hour, two hours. This is Jaime Aleman. And we are at my place on Sunland, California.
但尽管它们噪音大且有废气，吹叶机在清理院子里的落叶方面也非常快。对于那些不仅维护自己的草坪，还要维护许多草坪的人来说，速度非常重要。比如一个普通的房子，可能半小时、45分钟。但一个大房子，你要花大约一小时、两小时。这是海梅·阿莱曼。我们现在在加利福尼亚州桑兰的我的住处。
How long have you been a gardener? Over 30 years. I met Jaime in his hilly Southern California neighborhood. Horse tracks marked the mud where a sidewalk should be, rows of ranch houses, more pastures and native plants than manicured lawns. In 1989, Jaime Alaman left his job in office supplies to start his own landscaping company. His father-in-law gave him a handful of clients, and he remembers the first time he ever used a leaf blower.
你做园丁多久了？超过30年了。我在他位于南加州多山的社区见到了海梅。马蹄印在泥地上留下了痕迹，那里本该是人行道，一排排牧场风格的房子，牧场和原生植物比修剪整齐的草坪更多。1989年，海梅·阿拉曼辞去了办公用品的工作，开始了自己的景观美化公司。他的岳父给了他一些客户，他记得自己第一次使用吹叶机的情景。
It's a good thing to blow the leaves, and fast. You do that with a blower, and it looks clean and nice. A landscaper often starts their business when an older gardener gives them a few houses or clients. Through much of the 20th century, a lot of the gardeners in Los Angeles were of Japanese descent. But throughout the 80s and 90s, that began to shift to mostly Latin American gardeners.
吹树叶是件好事，而且很快。你用吹叶机做这件事，看起来既干净又漂亮。园丁通常在老园丁把一些房子或客户转给他们时开始自己的生意。在20世纪的大部分时间里，洛杉矶的许多园丁都是日裔。但在整个80年代和90年代，这种情况开始转向以拉丁裔园丁为主。
Their circuit of clients became known as La Ruta, the root. The difference between failure and success for a gardener is all about speed. They get paid per lawn, and the margins are already small. Using a blower instead of a rake means they can work a bigger circuit of lawns in a single day. But as Jaime began his business and expanding La Ruta, tension had been building for almost a decade. Word began to spread through the community that the Los Angeles City Council was seriously
他们的客户圈被称为“La Ruta”，即路线。对于园丁来说，失败与成功的区别全在于速度。他们按草坪收费，利润空间本来就很小。使用吹叶机而不是耙子意味着他们一天可以完成更多的草坪工作。但随着海梅开始他的生意并扩展“La Ruta”，紧张局势已经酝酿了近十年。社区里开始传言洛杉矶市议会正在认真
considering a ban on gas-powered leaf blowers. I remember. I remember the whole thing when this thing started. We were kind of upset because they wanted to take one of the best tools to clean the house. Jaime saw this proposed ban as an obvious threat to his young business. And he started to ask around, looking for some advice on how to fight it. This is actually like a Hollywood story to tell the truth. This is Dr. Alvaro Huerta, associate professor in the Urban and Regional Planning Department
考虑禁止燃气吹叶机。我记得。我记得这一切开始的时候。我们有点心烦，因为他们想拿走清理房子最好的工具之一。海梅认为这项拟议的禁令对他刚起步的生意构成了明显的威胁。他开始四处打听，寻求关于如何对抗它的建议。说实话，这简直就像一个好莱坞故事。这是阿尔瓦罗·韦尔塔博士，加州理工大学波莫纳分校城市与区域规划系的副教授。
of Cal Poly Pomona. But back in 1996, he was a young Chicano activist from Boyle Heights. Alvaro had a small group of activist friends who took on some big issues, like getting UCLA to provide financial aid to undocumented students. One night, around May of 1996, Alvaro was drinking with some friends, watching a boxing match, when Jaime Alamon came up and confronted him. Jaime approached me, he was like calling me out. And then he said, you guys act like you're from the community but here we are,
但在1996年，他还是博伊尔高地的一名年轻的奇卡诺活动家。阿尔瓦罗有一小群活动家朋友，他们处理一些重大问题，比如让加州大学洛杉矶分校为无证学生提供经济援助。1996年5月左右的一个晚上，阿尔瓦罗正和朋友们喝酒看拳击比赛，海梅·阿拉曼走过来质问他。海梅走近我，他就像是在挑战我。然后他说，你们表现得好像你们来自社区，但我们在这里，
you know, the Jardineros, the City Valley wants to take away our leafblowers and you guys are not are not doing anything. Like what are you going to do for us, you know? Jaime asked Alvaro to take on the fight to save the leaf blower. I just said yes, not knowing what I was getting into. Pretty quickly, Alvaro and a small group of friends and activists sprung into action. Since gardeners are independent contractors and self-employed business owners, this would not be a traditional union labor kind of fight. But they wanted to show that they were united. And so the Association of Latin American Gardeners of Los Angeles, or ALAGLA, was born.
你知道，园丁们，市议会想要拿走我们的吹叶机，而你们却什么都不做。你们打算为我们做什么，你知道吗？海梅请求阿尔瓦罗承担起拯救吹叶机的斗争。我只是说了好，不知道自己卷入了什么。很快，阿尔瓦罗和一小群朋友及活动家就采取了行动。由于园丁是独立承包商和自雇企业主，这不会是一场传统的工会劳工斗争。但他们想展示他们是团结的。于是，洛杉矶拉丁裔园丁协会（ALAGLA）诞生了。
And Jaime joined right away. We got together in different areas because there's gardeners all over. So we have meetings here in the Valley, West LA, Hollywood, and all over. ALAGLA's opponents were no small adversary. Not only were these leaf blower bands widely popular among non-landscapers and people who enjoy sleep, but this one was about to become law. It seemed that the city council had a lot of momentum. So this bill, it took, let's say, six months a year to get to that point.
海梅立刻加入了。我们在不同地区聚会，因为园丁遍布各地。所以我们在山谷、西洛杉矶、好莱坞和各地都有会议。ALAGLA的对手不是小角色。这些吹叶机禁令不仅在非园艺工作者和喜欢睡觉的人中广受欢迎，而且这项禁令即将成为法律。看起来市议会势头很猛。所以这项法案，花了，比如说，六个月到一年才达到那个地步。
So we got there like at the eleventh hour. On a spring day of May 1996, not long after Jaime approached Alvaro, the subject of leaf blowers came up in Los Angeles City Hall. On the balance of the regular agenda, item nine is an ordinance first reading which would prohibit all gas-powered leaf blowers within 500 feet of a residence. This is audio from Los Angeles City Council in 1996. The chambers were packed. The leaf blower ban had been generating a lot of buzz and the person championing this effort was council member Marvin Rowdy. Society is going through many, many changes.
所以我们在最后一刻赶到了。1996年5月的一个春日，在海梅找到阿尔瓦罗后不久，吹叶机的话题在洛杉矶市政厅被提了出来。在常规议程的平衡中，第九项是一项条例初读，将禁止在住宅500英尺范围内使用所有燃气吹叶机。这是1996年洛杉矶市议会的音频。会议厅挤满了人。吹叶机禁令引起了很大轰动，而推动这一努力的人是议员马文·劳迪。社会正在经历许多许多变化。
And one of those changes is that more people are working in the home. Again, this was pre-pandemic, pre-video chat 1990s, but there was a growing number of people working by phone and running businesses out of their houses. As council member Browdy put it, the leaf blowers were disruptive. And how we measure that is by the number of complaints that we get and we get very very many. So he proposed a simple solution. It's a one-line ordinance and it in effect says that gasoline powered leaf blowers are prohibited. Though noise seemed to be the animating factor, Councilmember Browdy laid out three reasons
其中一个变化是越来越多的人在家工作。再说一次，这是大流行前、视频聊天前的1990年代，但有越来越多的人通过电话工作并在家里经营生意。正如劳迪议员所说，吹叶机具有破坏性。我们衡量这一点的方法是根据我们收到的投诉数量，我们收到了非常非常多。所以他提出了一个简单的解决方案。这是一项单行条例，实际上它说禁止使用燃气吹叶机。虽然噪音似乎是核心因素，但劳迪议员提出了三个理由
for the law, which echoed the complaints in other cities. Number one, the sound of leaf blowers. It drowned out dinners on the back patio, it interrupted phone calls, or perhaps worst of all, it woke up the entire neighborhood at 7am on Saturday mornings. Number 2, the dust. For decades, Los Angeles had been trying to address air quality issues, and leafblowers were blowing all types of dust and particulate matter into the air. Which is related to reason number three, emissions.
支持这项法律，这呼应了其他城市的投诉。第一，吹叶机的声音。它淹没了后院的晚餐，打断了电话，或者最糟糕的是，它在周六早上7点吵醒了整个社区。第二，灰尘。几十年来，洛杉矶一直试图解决空气质量问题，而吹叶机把各种灰尘和颗粒物吹到了空气中。这与第三个理由有关，即排放。
Gas-powered leaf blowers run on a small two-stroke engine that even by 1996 standards was polluting and inefficient. In short, it was a trade-off. You could have lawns with fewer leaves on them or cleaner air and quieter neighborhoods. But if this ordinance seemed like a no-brainer to some, city council hadn't really thought about who was on the other side of these blowers. People like Jaime Alaman. As a landscaper, he was understandably nervous about this crackdown on a tool that he used every day.
燃气吹叶机使用小型二冲程发动机，即使按1996年的标准，它也是污染严重且效率低下的。简而言之，这是一种权衡。你可以拥有落叶较少的草坪，或者拥有更清洁的空气和更安静的社区。但如果这项条例对某些人来说是显而易见的，市议会并没有真正考虑过这些吹叶机的使用者是谁。像海梅·阿拉曼这样的人。作为一名景观设计师，他对这种针对他每天使用的工具的打击感到紧张是可以理解的。
So yeah, we have to raise the prices. We want to spend more time and as long as they pay more, that's okay. If you were a landscaper with a wealthy clientele, this change might not affect you too much. Raising prices could lose you a couple of clients, but it might pencil out. However, if you were a landscaper working in less wealthy neighborhoods, or if you had older clients on a fixed income, this could seriously affect your ability to make a living. In City Hall, the proponents of the band came ready to make a point. They wore matching yellow lapel pins and hammered home the health effects of breathing bad air
所以是的，我们必须提高价格。我们想花更多时间，只要他们付更多钱，那没问题。如果你是一位拥有富有客户群的景观设计师，这种变化可能不会对你影响太大。提高价格可能会让你失去几个客户，但可能还能收支平衡。然而，如果你是一位在不太富裕的社区工作的景观设计师，或者如果你的老客户收入固定，这可能会严重影响你的生计。在市政厅，禁令的支持者准备好表达观点。他们佩戴着配套的黄色翻领别针，并强调呼吸污浊空气
and emissions. By contrast, the pro-leap blower side of the room had a lot of empty seats. A few gardeners expressed concern about their livelihoods, but they were nowhere near as In contrast, the pro-leaf blower side of the room had a lot of empty seats. A few gardeners expressed concern about their livelihoods, but they were nowhere near as organized as their opponents. But the thing about city ordinances is they typically take a few meetings to pass, so this first hearing, though important to set the tone, was definitely not the end of the line.
和排放带来的健康影响。相比之下，支持吹叶机的一方房间里有很多空座位。一些园丁表达了对生计的担忧，但他们远没有对手组织得那么好。但城市条例的问题在于，它们通常需要几次会议才能通过，所以这次初次听证会，虽然对定调很重要，但绝对不是终点。
City council would next meet to discuss the leaf blower ban in November 1996, and then a vote. This meant Alvaro and Alagla would have a little time to get creative and mount a counter effort against the ban. And we're very confrontational, nonviolent, but very forceful and uncompromising. Alagla saw that their best chance was to flip public opinion and shift the focus from the noisy polluting blower to the hardworking gardener. That's how we started to take it to another level where we were able to engage in political
市议会接下来将在1996年11月开会讨论吹叶机禁令，然后进行投票。这意味着阿尔瓦罗和ALAGLA将有一点时间发挥创意，发起反击。我们非常有对抗性，非暴力，但非常有力且毫不妥协。ALAGLA看到他们最好的机会是扭转公众舆论，将焦点从吵闹、污染的吹叶机转移到勤劳的园丁身上。这就是我们开始将其提升到另一个层次的方式，我们能够参与政治
theater. After the meeting, Alvaro and the others began planning protests trying to attract the press. They organized a barefoot walk through downtown holding brooms to illustrate how this ban would impoverish them. Y'all want us to use brooms instead of a leaf blower. Here, why don't you use a broom too? You have advanced technological equipment, yet you want the gardeners to go back to feudal times. equipment, yet you want the gardeners to go back to feudal times."
戏剧。会议结束后，阿尔瓦罗和其他人开始策划抗议活动，试图吸引媒体。他们组织了一场赤脚穿过市中心的游行，手里拿着扫帚，以说明这项禁令将如何使他们陷入贫困。你们想让我们用扫帚代替吹叶机。来，为什么你不也用扫帚呢？你们拥有先进的技术设备，却想让园丁回到封建时代。
Alagla was up against public opinion and the power of celebrity. But they knew that they could put faces behind these hated machines. And deploying a couple PR stunts worked. Their cause started to attract attention. And Alvaro remembers, ABC, NBC, BBC, The New Yorker, New York Times, everybody, everybody was covering it. The thing that started grabbing my attention is the fact that most of the gardeners were Mexican, right, or Latin American. This is Ruben Ortiz Torres, an artist and professor at the University of California San Diego. He found it symbolic to see these futuristic looking machines wielded by Latino immigrant
ALAGLA面对的是公众舆论和名人的力量。但他们知道，他们可以为这些被憎恨的机器赋予面孔。部署一些公关噱头奏效了。他们的事业开始引起关注。阿尔瓦罗记得，美国广播公司、美国全国广播公司、英国广播公司、《纽约客》、《纽约时报》，每个人，每个人都在报道它。开始引起我注意的一点是，大多数园丁都是墨西哥人，或者拉丁裔。这是鲁本·奥尔蒂斯·托雷斯，加州大学圣地亚哥分校的艺术家和教授。他发现看到这些看起来充满未来感的机器被拉丁裔移民
laborers. These laborers had a kind of power. They are the owners of their means of production. They own the tools. They're their own boss with their own company. So in a way, owning the company puts you in a different position in your attempt to achieve the American dream. As national and international news outlets covered the Gardner's protests, LA's public perception of leafblowers became a little more complex.
劳工使用具有象征意义。这些劳工拥有一种力量。他们是自己生产资料的所有者。他们拥有工具。他们是自己的老板，拥有自己的公司。所以从某种意义上说，拥有公司使你在实现美国梦的过程中处于不同的位置。随着国内和国际新闻媒体报道园丁的抗议活动，洛杉矶公众对吹叶机的看法变得复杂了一些。
And going into the next hearing in November, Alagla was ready. Back at the first hearing in May, the anti-leaf flower side was full and organized. The pro-leaf flower side was sparse, but this time around, the gardeners showed up in force. Rows and rows of men packed the benches, and several guys who looked like they came straight from work stood at the back of the chamber in baseball caps and denim jackets.
进入11月的下一次听证会时，ALAGLA已经准备好了。回到5月的第一次听证会，反吹叶机一方人满为患且组织严密。支持吹叶机的一方很稀疏，但这一次，园丁们倾巢而出。一排排的男人挤满了长椅，几个看起来像是直接从工作中赶来的家伙戴着棒球帽和牛仔夹克站在会议厅后面。
It was like us versus them. The little guy versus big bad government. Poor Latino immigrants just struggling to get by against these rich Westsiders who want to sleep in because they're bothered by the leaf blower. You know, that wakes them up at 7 in the morning. We started to expose these contradictions. At one point a gardener named Roy Amazu approached the podium with his leaf blower in hand and turned to the audience to acknowledge the gardeners directly. All the gardeners, please stand up.
这就像是我们对抗他们。小人物对抗邪恶的大政府。贫穷的拉丁裔移民只是为了生存而挣扎，对抗那些因为被吹叶机打扰而想睡懒觉的富有的西区人。你知道，那在早上7点吵醒了他们。我们开始揭露这些矛盾。有一次，一位名叫罗伊·阿马祖的园丁拿着他的吹叶机走上讲台，转向观众，直接向园丁们致意。所有的园丁，请站起来。
As the dozens of men in the benches stood up, the room erupted with applause. Peter Graves from Mission Impossible was not at this hearing. But the anti-leaf blower side did deploy their other most notable celebrity, Julie Newmar, the original Catwoman. I'm a movie star and my gardener doesn't use a leaf blower. I asked her not to. Behind Julie Newmar was a crowd of white haired elders. I am the much maligned, long-suffering, sometimes hated, upper middle class person.
当长椅上的几十名男子站起来时，房间里爆发出掌声。来自《碟中谍》的彼得·格雷夫斯没有参加这次听证会。但反吹叶机一方确实部署了他们另一位最著名的名人，朱莉·纽玛，原版猫女。我是电影明星，我的园丁不用吹叶机。我要求他不要用。在朱莉·纽玛身后是一群白发苍苍的长者。我是那个被严重诋毁、长期受苦、有时被憎恨的中上层阶级人士。
But I'm, ladies and gentlemen, I am also a single working mother of a multi-handicapped child. I work at home, I have to. And last year, losing two to four hours a week from work, from the machinery, and this year about 10 to four hours a week from work from the machinery and this year about 10 to 15 hours. Then Newmar brought up the existing noise laws that seemed to not stop the blowers even when they exceeded the decibel level or allowed time frame. She was not happy with the way government had failed to intervene.
但是，女士们先生们，我也是一位患有多重残疾儿童的单身职场母亲。我在家工作，我必须这样做。去年，因为这些机器，我每周损失两到四个小时的工作时间，而今年大约是10到15个小时。然后纽玛提到了现有的噪音法律，这些法律似乎即使在吹叶机超过分贝水平或允许的时间范围时也无法阻止它们。她对政府未能干预的方式感到不满。
But we need laws. We need laws to keep from hurting each other. And here's the important part. Otherwise we take the law in our own hands. Thank you. And I've never broken the law, but I'm thinking, mind you, only thinking about buying a hatchet and smashing a few tires just to let out my anger. Please don't do that and please stand aside and let's... Because I don't think you hear us so far. You've been powerless, powerless to do anything for any of us.
但我们需要法律。我们需要法律来防止互相伤害。这是重要的一点。否则我们就自己动手。谢谢。我从未触犯过法律，但我正在考虑，请注意，只是考虑买一把斧头，砸碎几个轮胎，只是为了发泄我的愤怒。请不要那样做，请站到一边，让我们……因为我觉得你们到现在还没听见我们的声音。你们一直无能为力，对我们任何人都无能为力。
As she wrapped up, Newmar put on her reading glasses and stepped aside. All right, thank you very much. While some on the anti-leap blower side clapped, the gardeners sat quietly. Neumar seemed to be at her wits end, and the Gardners would have to figure out an effective response to this impassioned argument. This time around, the Gardners had a strong, simple message.
当她结束发言时，纽玛戴上老花镜，退到一边。好的，非常感谢。虽然反吹叶机一方的一些人鼓掌，但园丁们静静地坐着。纽玛似乎已经束手无策，而园丁们必须想出一个有效的回应来应对这个充满激情的论点。这一次，园丁们有一个强有力、简单的信息。
This ban would make it hard to make a living. If you ban this, it's going to kill our businesses. It's going to hurt us badly. It's going to hurt us badly. It's going to affect us economically. Anytime somebody said anything in favor of Gardner's, the room erupted in applause. A lot of my customers are not movie stars. We definitely need your help. So think about that.
这项禁令将使谋生变得困难。如果你禁止这个，它会扼杀我们的生意。它会严重伤害我们。它会严重伤害我们。它会在经济上影响我们。每当有人说出支持园丁的话时，房间里就会爆发出掌声。我的很多客户都不是电影明星。我们绝对需要你们的帮助。所以考虑一下。
Thank you. OK, thank you. But the anti-leaf blower side still had more ammo. The council president called up Dick Hingson, a representative from the environmental nonprofit Sierra Club. Quality of life and environmental quality includes especially where people sleep and recreate those quiet residential areas where we try to find respite.
谢谢。好的，谢谢。但反吹叶机一方还有更多弹药。市议会主席叫来了迪克·辛森，环境非营利组织塞拉俱乐部的代表。生活质量和环境质量特别包括人们睡觉和娱乐的地方，那些我们试图寻找喘息机会的安静住宅区。
Sierra Club was not known for wading into big city issues, but for leafblowers they would come down from the mountain. Instead of focusing on noise as a mere hindrance to rest or productivity, Hingson went big. He focused on the spiritual value of silence. We need these areas as open space and not just for the eyes but also for the ears and the mind and the heart. When public comment ended, the fight was handed over to the city council. And compared to the first hearing, the workers were front and center in many of the council members' arguments. So much so, that it was hard to tell what the vote might be.
塞拉俱乐部并不以介入大城市问题而闻名，但对于吹叶机，他们会从山上下来。辛森没有把噪音仅仅视为对休息或生产力的阻碍，而是放眼全局。他专注于沉默的精神价值。我们需要这些区域作为开放空间，不仅是为了眼睛，也是为了耳朵、思想和心灵。当公众评论结束时，斗争交给了市议会。与第一次听证会相比，工人们在许多议员的论点中处于中心位置。以至于很难判断投票结果会如何。
Some seemed moved by the gardener's concern. One had clearly flipped entirely, and one even proposed a substitute motion banning loud machines instead of gas-powered ones. But ultimately, City Council voted down the substitute motion, instead deciding to vote motion banning loud machines instead of gas-powered ones. But ultimately, city council voted down the substitute motion, instead deciding to vote on the single line ordinance. After a long battle, this was the moment of truth. City council would finally decide. When they brought up the ban on gas-powered leaf blowers, it passed.
有些人似乎被园丁的担忧所打动。一个人显然完全改变了立场，甚至有人提议用禁止吵闹机器代替禁止燃气机器的替代动议。但最终，市议会否决了替代动议，而是决定对单行条例进行投票。经过长期的斗争，这是关键时刻。市议会最终将做出决定。当他们提出禁止燃气吹叶机时，它通过了。
Easily. Ten votes to three. It would soon become illegal to use a gas-powered leafblower in the city of Los Angeles. The Association of Latin American Gardeners of Los Angeles wasn't surprised by the loss, just disappointed. Alvaro Huerta, for one, found the new ban ridiculous. Well, there's the noise, there's the pollution. What I think about that is that they're like exaggerated. Right? You know, we live in an industrialized country
轻松通过。十票对三票。在洛杉矶市使用燃气吹叶机很快就会成为非法。洛杉矶拉丁裔园丁协会对失败并不感到惊讶，只是感到失望。阿尔瓦罗·韦尔塔认为这项新禁令很荒谬。嗯，有噪音，有污染。我对那件事的看法是它们被夸大了。对吧？你知道，我们生活在一个工业化国家
and we have to put up with noise. We have to put up with pollution. Like go to the mountains or something and then the bears will be attacking you. So there's always a problem somewhere. If caught violating the ordinance, gardeners could face a thousand dollar fine and up to six months in jail.
我们必须忍受噪音。我们必须忍受污染。就像去山上什么的，然后熊会攻击你。所以总是有问题存在。如果被抓到违反条例，园丁可能面临一千美元的罚款和最高六个月的监禁。
Six months in jail for using a leaf blower seemed like cruel and unusual punishment to many, especially for the gardeners themselves because this threatened their livelihoods. For a while, they decided to collectively ignore the ordinance. In defiance of the new ban, the gardenners kept using the gas-powered leaf blowers. And in January 1998, when the law was about to go into full effect, Alagla decided it was time to deploy the nuclear option. The hunger strike was, that was the climax of our move. The hunger strike was that was the climax of our movement
对许多人来说，使用吹叶机被判六个月监禁似乎是残酷和不寻常的惩罚，特别是对园丁自己而言，因为这威胁到了他们的生计。有一段时间，他们决定集体无视该条例。为了反抗这项新禁令，园丁们继续使用燃气吹叶机。1998年1月，当法律即将全面生效时，ALAGLA决定是时候部署核选项了。绝食抗议是我们运动的高潮。
They wanted to delay if not outright stop enforcement of this new law So they decided to go on hunger strike After the break the LA Gardner hunger strike of 1998 On a cold gray Saturday, January 3rd, 1998, several gardeners ascended the steps of City Hall with big jackets and blankets. There were 11 hunger strikers. Around them, dozens of gardeners showed up to support. Many, including the organizers, set up camp on the front lawn. And they slept in front of City Hall. Every single day, there was like more and more pressure. So we started with like 11 hunger strikers one day, and then the next day there's 50.
他们想推迟，如果不是彻底停止执行这项新法律的话。所以他们决定进行绝食抗议。休息之后，1998年的洛杉矶园丁绝食抗议。1998年1月3日，一个寒冷阴沉的周六，几名园丁穿着厚外套、裹着毯子登上了市政厅的台阶。有11名绝食抗议者。在他们周围，几十名园丁赶来支持。许多人，包括组织者，在前草坪上扎营。他们睡在市政厅前。每一天，压力都越来越大。所以我们开始时有11名绝食抗议者，然后第二天就有50人。
And then people see it on TV. The spectacle of dozens of men camping on the lawn, the workers hungry and cold, caught the attention of the press while ratcheting up the pressure on city council. Alagla wanted city Council and Mayor Richard Reardon to repeal the ban. As the days passed, the men continued their strike. City Council planned to vote later in the week, not to overturn the law,
然后人们在电视上看到了。几十名男子在草坪上露营的景象，工人们饥寒交迫，引起了媒体的注意，同时也加大了对市议会的压力。ALAGLA希望市议会和市长理查德·里尔登废除禁令。随着日子一天天过去，男人们继续他们的罢工。市议会计划在周内晚些时候投票，不是为了推翻法律，
but to reduce the punishment for using a leaf blower. Finally, on Wednesday, under pressure, the mayor agreed to meet with the gardeners. It forced the mayor to meet with us because he didn't want to meet with us before. And one time this idiot, he shows up at a hunger strike when we're negotiating with him eating a hamburger. Several days in, four of the men had become dangerously weak and dropped out at the request of doctors.
而是为了减少使用吹叶机的惩罚。最终，在周三，在压力之下，市长同意与园丁会面。这迫使市长与我们见面，因为他之前不想见我们。有一次这个白痴，在我们和他谈判时，他吃着汉堡包出现在绝食抗议现场。几天后，四名男子变得极其虚弱，应医生的要求退出了。
But the remaining seven hunger strikers made it seven days, to Friday. That morning, rain dumped on the city. Finally, a few city council members and Mayor Reardon pledged in writing to negotiate with the gardeners. They likely wouldn't stop enforcement, but they did vote to lessen the punishment. Which is the jail, $1, dollars in misdemeanors and just make it into a fine,
但剩下的七名绝食抗议者坚持了七天，直到周五。那天早上，雨倾盆而下。最终，几位市议会议员和市长里尔登书面承诺与园丁谈判。他们可能不会停止执行，但他们确实投票减轻了惩罚。也就是监禁、罚款和轻罪，只是把它变成罚款，
two hundred and seventy one dollars fine. It's like a parking ticket. So it was still bad, but it was like a fine only. It fell short of the sweeping victory Alagla wanted, but a win was a win, at least enough of a win for the gardeners to end the hunger strike and go home. So at first it was like these guys are bad, they're polluters, the leaf blower, the sound, the pollution, blah, blah, blah. And then all of a sudden it's like, why are you picking on these little guys? You know, they're workers and they just want to survive and all that because we changed
两百七十一美元的罚款。就像一张停车罚单。所以情况仍然很糟糕，但只是罚款而已。这没有达到ALAGLA想要的全面胜利，但赢了就是赢了，至少足以让园丁们结束绝食抗议回家。所以起初就像是这些人很坏，他们是污染者，吹叶机，声音，污染，等等。然后突然之间，就像是，你们为什么要欺负这些小人物？你知道，他们是工人，他们只是想生存等等，因为我们改变了
the narrative. Even though public opinion had shifted, the ban on gas powered leaf blowers still became law. But if you spent any time in Los Angeles over the past 30 years, you'll know that it is not a place free of the motorized wine of the leafblower. After the ordinance with the reduced fine went into full effect, Alvaro and the rest of Alagla were not yet done with the leafblower wars. They hatched one final plan.
叙事。尽管公众舆论已经转变，但禁止燃气吹叶机仍然成为了法律。但如果你在过去30年里在洛杉矶待过，你就会知道这里并不是一个没有吹叶机马达嗡嗡声的地方。在罚款减少的条例全面生效后，阿尔瓦罗和ALAGLA的其余成员并没有结束吹叶机战争。他们制定了最后一个计划。
Since taking the issue head on with a hunger strike didn't move the city to stop the leaf blower ban, they decided to stop using grand moral arguments and just circumvent the thing. These idiots in City Hall, these morons, these imbeciles, they passed a law banning gas-powered leaf blowers. Apparently, a friend of the group, a lawn equipment mechanic, proposed converting some of the leaf blowers off of gasoline. Because why don't we convert them into methanol? So that's what we did.
既然通过绝食抗议正面解决问题并没有促使城市停止吹叶机禁令，他们决定停止使用宏大的道德论点，只是绕过它。市政厅里的这些白痴，这些笨蛋，这些傻瓜，他们通过了一项禁止燃气吹叶机的法律。显然，该组织的一位朋友，一名草坪设备修理工，提议将一些吹叶机从汽油改为其他燃料。因为为什么我们不把它们改装成甲醇呢？所以我们就这么做了。
So we got like a hundred gardeners or more even, convert their machines into methanol, because they didn't say repeal motorized leaf blowers. They didn't say that. They say gas powered. Methanol's not banned. These converted blowers would still be loud and polluting, but technically legal.
所以我们有一百名甚至更多的园丁，把他们的机器改装成了甲醇，因为他们没有说废除机动吹叶机。他们没那么说。他们说的是燃气动力。甲醇没有被禁止。这些改装后的吹叶机仍然会很吵且有污染，但从技术上讲是合法的。
Alagla thought that if a few guys with methanol blowers got tickets from the police, that they could get these cases thrown out and ultimately muddy the water on enforcement. Because how could the police tell if a leaf blower was using gas or methanol from afar? Finding out would be difficult, time consuming, and maybe they'd stop checking altogether. Which is ultimately what did happen. Maybe it was because of the hunger strike, or maybe it was the general shift in public opinion that did it, but ultimately the leaf blower ban didn't really work. The police decided to not enforce the law. The Gardners lost the fight in City Hall, but in the end, they won a quiet, actually
ALAGLA认为，如果几个使用甲醇吹叶机的家伙被警察开了罚单，他们可以把这些案件驳回，并最终搅浑执法的水。因为警察怎么能从远处分辨吹叶机是用汽油还是甲醇呢？查明这一点将是困难、耗时的，也许他们会完全停止检查。这最终确实发生了。也许是因为绝食抗议，或者是因为公众舆论的普遍转变，但最终吹叶机禁令并没有真正奏效。警察决定不执行该法律。园丁们在市政厅输掉了斗争，但最终，他们赢得了一场安静的，实际上
maybe not so quiet, victory. The ban passed, but without real enforcement, the Gardners kept their leafblowers. The leafblower wars faded into the background for a while. But in 2024, nearly three decades after Olagla's hunger strike, they're beginning to flare up again. And this time, the gas-powered leafblower might actually be on its way out. Lawn equipment, you wouldn't believe it, surpassed cars and light duty trucks as a major source of pollution.
也许不是那么安静的胜利。禁令通过了，但没有真正的执行，园丁们保留了他们的吹叶机。吹叶机战争消失在背景中一段时间。但在2024年，在ALAGLA绝食抗议近三十年后，它们又开始爆发了。这一次，燃气吹叶机可能真的要被淘汰了。草坪设备，你不会相信，超过了汽车和轻型卡车，成为主要的污染源。
This is Michael Cacciotti. trucks or past cars and light duty trucks as a major source of pollution. This is Michael Cacciotti. I'm a five-time mayor, current council member with the historic city of South Pasadena, California. And he is currently the vice chair of the South Coast Air Quality Management District, which aims to control air pollution in a huge chunk of Southern California. Michael has been a strong voice in the present-day fight against leaf blowers. The science on gas-powered leaf blowers is pretty damning. Putting aside the evidence of significant hearing loss when subjected to that level
这是迈克尔·卡乔蒂。卡车或超过汽车和轻型卡车，成为主要的污染源。这是迈克尔·卡乔蒂。我是五届市长，现任加利福尼亚州南帕萨迪纳历史名城的议员。他目前是南海岸空气质量管理区的副主席，该区旨在控制南加州大部分地区的空气污染。迈克尔一直是当今反对吹叶机斗争中的强有力声音。关于燃气吹叶机的科学研究相当令人震惊。撇开在那种水平下遭受持续噪音会导致严重听力损失的证据不谈，
of sustained noise, the emissions are serious. According to at least one frequently cited study, using a single gas-powered leaf blower for one hour is the equivalent of driving a modern car the 15 plus hours from Los Angeles to Denver. And the reason is, as you probably know, in your cars and required by law in the 80s because of all the pollution in California, followed by the nation and all the manufacturers have catalytic converters. The catalytic converter breaks down many of the pollutants coming out of the car exhaust, which reduces smog.
排放问题很严重。根据至少一项经常被引用的研究，使用一台燃气吹叶机一小时相当于驾驶现代汽车从洛杉矶到丹佛行驶15个多小时。原因正如你可能知道的那样，在你的汽车中，由于加州的所有污染，80年代法律要求，随后全国跟进，所有制造商都有催化转化器。催化转化器分解了汽车尾气中排出的许多污染物，从而减少了烟雾。
On the other hand, lawn equipment has no catalytic converters. You use gasoline, you use two-stroke oil, you mix it up, it's a toxic combination. Battery technology and electric leaf blowers have come a long way in the last 30 years, so the modern-day fight is mainly about getting people to switch to electric. With the new statewide law in California, which bans the sale of gas-powered lawn equipment and other small off-road engines, Michael is working to get landscapers set up with that electric gear. Some like Jaime Alaman are reluctant to make the shift. The gas blower is fast, but with these tools, electric is going to take us more time, and
另一方面，草坪设备没有催化转化器。你使用汽油，你使用二冲程机油，你混合在一起，这是一种有毒的组合。电池技术和电动吹叶机在过去30年里取得了长足进步，所以当今的斗争主要是让人们改用电动。随着加州新的全州法律禁止销售燃气草坪设备和其他小型非道路发动机，迈克尔正在努力让景观设计师配备那些电动装备。有些人像海梅·阿拉曼一样不愿做出改变。燃气吹叶机很快，但有了这些工具，电动吹叶机将花费我们更多时间，而且
the job is not going to be as nice as the regular blower. Jaime bought a new electric setup just in case but says that he'll keep using the gas-powered one as long as he can. He says it's more powerful, he doesn't have to deal with battery charging, and the electric blower definitely isn't quiet. No, they're different. The noise is lower, but the sound. It's like a higher, like this tiny eeeeee. Yeah. And that'll like this. This time around, the government did offer subsidies to get gardeners switched, and some
工作效果不会像普通吹叶机那样好。海梅买了一套新的电动设备以防万一，但表示只要能用，他就会继续使用燃气的那台。他说它动力更强，他不必处理电池充电问题，而且电动吹叶机绝对不安静。不，它们不同。噪音较低，但声音。它就像一种更高的，像这种微小的“咿——”声。是的。那会像这样。这一次，政府确实提供了补贴来让园丁们转换，一些
municipalities made a good faith effort to work with them. But in reality, the electric leaf blower is at best an imperfect alternative. If you remember the three central arguments against blowers, noise, dust, and emissions, the shift to electric really only solves the third. Throughout the fight in the 1990s, representatives from the leaf blower manufacturers promised quieter, cleaner machines. But as multiple council members pointed out in the meetings, they never delivered on that promise of a quiet leaf blower. It seems, in some part, that this statewide ban
市政当局也做出了真诚的努力与他们合作。但实际上，电动吹叶机充其量是一个不完美的替代品。如果你还记得反对吹叶机的三个核心论点：噪音、灰尘和排放，改用电动确实只解决了第三个。在1990年代的斗争中，吹叶机制造商的代表承诺提供更安静、更清洁的机器。但正如多位议员在会议中指出的那样，他们从未兑现那个安静吹叶机的承诺。看起来，在某种程度上，这项全州禁令
is aimed at forcing those manufacturers to come up with better solutions. Whether or not it works is another thing entirely. I do believe in those mandates. That's artist and professor Ruben Ortiz Torres again. There's all sorts of problems with gas that I don't need to explain. They should be substituted by machines that don't work. We should, again, work on the design, work on the technology. We should do this in concert with the gardeners. It's a straightforward idea.
旨在迫使这些制造商拿出更好的解决方案。它是否有效是另一回事。我确实相信这些授权。那是艺术家兼教授鲁本·奥尔蒂斯·托雷斯。汽油有各种各样的问题，我不需要解释。它们应该被不工作的机器所取代。我们应该再次在设计上努力，在技术上努力。我们应该与园丁们协同工作。这是一个直截了当的想法。
Involve gardeners in the political and design process, make sure they aren't penalized for doing the job they're hired for, and in the meantime, we can ask ourselves if beauty is a leafless yard or a quiet one. Back at Jaime Alamán's house, we sit in his backyard. It's a warm Southern California day, and the air over the valley is clear. You can see a haze toward downtown and the sun is bright. What does your dream yard look like? Like what's a beautiful
让园丁参与政治和设计过程，确保他们不会因为做他们被雇佣的工作而受到惩罚，与此同时，我们可以问问自己，美是无叶的院子还是安静的院子。回到海梅·阿拉曼的家，我们坐在他的后院。这是一个温暖的南加州日子，山谷上空的空气很清澈。你可以看到朝向市中心的雾霾，阳光很明亮。你梦想中的院子是什么样的？对你来说什么是美丽的
yard to you? A beautiful yard to me is to see the plants more natural. You can make a nice yard natural, I mean, trimming natural. There are leaves on Jaime's lawn and in the garden bed behind his patio too. The plants are beautiful, not too trimmed. We sit in the shade of a tall leafy tree and I think back to something Julie Newmar said in City Hall in 1996.
院子？对我来说，美丽的院子是看到植物更自然。你可以让一个漂亮的院子变得自然，我是说，修剪得自然。海梅的草坪上有树叶，他露台后面的花园里也有。植物很美，没有修剪得太整齐。我们坐在高大茂密的树荫下，我想起朱莉·纽玛1996年在市政厅说的一句话。
And with my radio full blast, I look out my windows made filthy by the leaf blowers and wonder why my neighbor needs a lawn that for 15 minutes is as clean as a billiard table. There's some mental insanity here. Jaime's lawn is no billiard table, but it's nice. It's crazy. Right now it's crazy because I haven't got time to weed it.
收音机开到最大声，我看着被吹叶机弄脏的窗户，想知道为什么我的邻居需要一个15分钟内像台球桌一样干净的草坪。这里面有些精神错乱。海梅的草坪不是台球桌，但它很不错。这很疯狂。现在这很疯狂，因为我没时间除草。
Yeah, because I mean, you don't have just like a flat lawn and it's really pretty, you know, it's like. Yeah, I love it and I enjoy come out here, but I don't like very, very like. Like manicured. Manicured, I don't like that. As I leave his house, we hear an electric leaf blower start up across the street. I look at Jaime and nod.
是的，因为我的意思是，你不仅仅有一个平坦的草坪，它真的很漂亮，你知道，它就像。是的，我喜欢它，我喜欢出来这里，但我不太喜欢非常、非常像。修剪整齐的。修剪整齐的，我不喜欢那样。当我离开他家时，我们听到街对面启动了一台电动吹叶机。我看着海梅，点了点头。
He waves goodbye and I walk down the road and past the horses and watch the freeway pulse in the distance. And the leaves fall from the tall swaying trees to land in the lawns below, short and green in the warm winter sun. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Phil Corbett, produced and edited by Nina Potuck. Additional production by Sara Bake, mix and sound design by Dara Hirsch, music by Swan Riel. Fact-checking by Liz Boyd. Phil makes a podcast at a desk in the mountains.
他挥手告别，我沿着路走，经过马群，看着远处高速公路的车流脉动。树叶从高大摇曳的树上落下，落在下方温暖冬日阳光下短小翠绿的草坪上。本周的《99% Invisible》由Phil Corbett报道，Nina Potuck制作和剪辑。Sara Bake参与制作，Dara Hirsch负责混音和声音设计，Swan Riel负责配乐。Liz Boyd负责事实核查。Phil在山里的一张书桌前制作播客。
It's called The Wind and it's all about listening. If you liked this episode, you might like Whiplaw or Dudas Priest on trial. Listen and subscribe at thewind.org. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. Nikita Abde is our intern. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella
它叫《The Wind》，内容全是关于倾听。如果你喜欢这一集，你可能也会喜欢《Whiplaw》或《Dudas Priest on trial》。请在thewind.org收听并订阅。Cathy Tu是我们的执行制片人。Kurt Kohlstedt是数字总监。Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。Nikita Abde是我们的实习生。团队其他成员包括Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Gabriella
Gladney, Martín González, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madón, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. beautiful uptown Oakland, California, home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the roots are Oakland first always. If this episode has you wondering how we ended up with the American ideal of the leafless, perfectly trimmed lawn aesthetic, we've done an episode about that too. way back in 2015. It's episode 177 called Lawn Order. It is a good one. I hope
Gladney、Martín González、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Ley、Lasha Madón、Jacob Maldonado-Medina、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg，以及我Roman Mars。99% Invisible的标志由Stephen Lawrence创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，也是奥克兰根源足球俱乐部的所在地，我很自豪能成为该俱乐部的社区所有者。其他球队可能会来来去去，但根源永远属于奥克兰。如果这一集让你好奇我们是如何形成美国那种无叶、修剪整齐的草坪审美理想的，我们以前也做过一集相关内容，早在2015年。那是第177集，名为《Lawn Order》。那一集很棒。我希望
you check it out. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你去听听看。在99PI.org上有那一集的链接以及《99PI》过去每一集的链接。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。